hey guys my name is Heinrich welcome
back to my channel firm learning and to
another coffee break with me it is
actually the first coffee that I was
drinking today this morning I worked a
lot in powerpoint on creating different
types of PowerPoint presentations for
the work that I'm currently doing and
this just reminded me of the time in
consulting where I literally created
thousands of PowerPoint pages over time
span of about six years I know that this
can actually be quite challenging it is
quite a learning development that you do
as a junior business analyst join in
consulting just learning the twits of
PowerPoint until you're a professional
of several years and then really doing
these slides well there's much more to
it than it seems creating good and
compelling PowerPoint presentations it's
not easy at all it's really a craft that
you learn over time and even after one
or two years in consulting you will
still not be there where you need to be
to really have these things at a
professional level where they meet they
need to be in the end for that I at some
point a few years ago created a course
it's called a course on slide writing on
creating PowerPoint presentations as top
consulting firms - and one of the topics
that I cover in this course is action
titles action titles is an important
part of every good professional
PowerPoint page it's the title that
appears in the very top of the page and
in this video I would like to give it
insight into how these action titles are
supposed to be written are supposed to
be crafted and if you now say who cares
about the title this is unimportant
you're completely wrong I can tell you
this action titles are a crucial part of
every power point presentation so let me
show you what's all about it and how to
write a good and compelling action title
this section is all about action titles
you already learned about action titles
in the introductory section on story
lines but I think it is important that
you really understand this concept in
detail because writing good action
titles is actually really important and
very crucial and key to create a winning
and successful story line so let's dive
into a bit more detail
and what I have here is an attempt of a
definition so this is my own very
personal definition please throw inside
me on that but I hope this helps you
understand this little better what it is
so let me just read it out to you action
titles are headers of a slide
presentation that summarizes the content
of the slide by formulating a complete
sentence so just to kind of go in it
point by point what exactly that means
so action titles are the headers of a
presentation so the header would be
something like this here again you see
that this is formulated in the style of
an action title and then second for the
slide presentation so yes we are talking
about your slide presentations like in
PowerPoint or other programs so this is
matching titles are used and they're
supposed to summarize the content here
again you know here's the definition and
then in the title you always try to
really kind of get the gist of what the
page is showing if you remember the
beginning there was the slide with the
horizontal and the vertical logic so
what of you two really right and winning
logic you need to make sure that the
action tire that's actually really
represent what the reader seeing on the
page and then finally they are written
by formulating a complete sentence so if
you look at these titles that I'd like
that you can see that it's really a
complete sentence so they have to create
a clear story line within a presentation
it is not just the title of a couple of
words right you see these people making
quite often that for instance on a slide
like that somebody would only write
actually title definition or something
like that and the problem with that is
that if you kind of create the headers
of your page or if a slide like that
it's not really possible to just skip
through all the pages and get the key
message because in most cases the titles
if you formulate them that way won't
really be speaking for themselves it's
usually then always necessary to really
read the page in order to get the key
message out of the page but with action
titles you know we want to enable
exactly that right so that the page
itself isn't that important anymore the
key message is already in the action
title
and I would like to introduce a very
familiar concept that can be helpful
when formulating action titles so if you
struggle to come up with a good action
title a reason for that could be that
your page actually lacks something that
is called so what right so what do we
mean when we talk about this so what so
imagine you look at a slide and you know
there could be all kinds of information
on the slide maybe you did a fancy
analysis you see different kinds of
charts and so on and maybe that's
interesting but you know sometimes you
will find yourself asking the question
so what right so why does it matter what
I see on the slide what is the
implication for my business you know for
for the project that I'm working on you
know that is kind of depicted here on
this slide and this is actually what
what many people do wrong they kind of
create some kind of analysis and maybe
it's fancy or maybe it's interesting but
they like to really kind of put out
there what implication of that is or you
could say you know they they do not
really show what the sort of the pages
so whenever you you kind of struggle and
wonder they really meet this page or do
I or kind of ask yourself what a good
action title would be maybe start with
asking yourself so what right why do you
need this page what is this what what is
the message
if you cannot really come up with the
good so what then probably this page
lacks a strong message a strong key
message and then you would either
usually need to take this page out or
you would need to restructure it to
recreate it for you to enable it to have
a key message so you know if you can't
come up with an action title ask
yourself critically if this award is
actually there what I will do now is I
will give you an exercise which I hope
will help you to really kind of
distinguish good from bad action titles
and you will see that in the next
section in this section I'm doing an
exercise with you that will hopefully
help you to distinguish good action
titles from bad or maybe not so good
action titles and
what you see here is a page and I
deleted the action title from the page
and I mean it's not important that you
understand all the nitty-gritty details
but just too quickly and if give you the
summary you see here kind of two regions
North America the first column here and
the second column Asia Pacific and then
there was some kind of quantification of
the EBIT potential so a bit is kind of a
term for the profit the profit of a
company so he was basically a profit
potential if the company would decide to
enter these regions and we showed that
here and saw the for the first question
that I would I would like to ask you is
what would be a good action title to
that page so please now pause the video
and take whatever time you need to come
up with a suggestion and then afterwards
we will discuss this suggestion so stop
the video now and then let's resume in a
few seconds okay now you have the
suggestion and maybe even write it down
if that helps you because this way you
cannot really cheat yourself and what
can we do now is we will go over a
couple of other suggestions that I
prepared for you and after each one we
can ask ourselves is this a good action
title or not and here again feel free to
pause the video after every kind of
action title suggestion that I will
blend in now and before then I tell you
what I think kind of ask yourself right
so is this a good action title or not
let's begin with the first suggestion
derived potentials for an expansion so
what this be a good title a good action
title to this page and again pause the
video if you need a second to think
about it and so here I would argue no
this is not a good action type why not
because actually it doesn't really fit
in the definition right and why not
because I mean basically it's not a full
sentence it doesn't really give you the
key
the kind of the key message of this page
in the title it just tells you that this
is a title that has something to do with
derived potentials for an expansion but
you know it doesn't really tell you what
the potential is right so is this
something good or bad it's the potential
positive or negative so basically to
really get the message out of it you
would really have to read the page
otherwise it's impossible and this is
kind of the opposite of what an action
title is supposed to do so this is the
second example let me read it out to you
expanding to new geographies creates a
positive able potential once again pause
the video if you like so this is a good
action title or not and here I would
argue that it's too generic so it's a
bit better than the first action title
because this actually is a first
sentence and it really conveys a message
right it tells you that there is a
positive EBIT potential in kind of
tapping these new geographies but it's
still too generic you can get much more
detail than that and we will see this in
future examples so here another new
suggestion for an action title again
pause the video is this a good action
title or not
expansion to North America and Asia
Pacific creates a positive potential and
what you see here this that this is now
much more concrete than the first one or
the second one because now it talks
about the specific regions that this
page is looking into so yes now we're
really getting closer to a good result
to a good action title and nevertheless
I would argue that you know you can do
better than that because when possible
it's always a good idea to really
quantify the things that you analyzed
and now this is what the next example is
all about
and here again expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific creates a
positive evil potential of 22 euro
million
so I mean what's wrong with that right
so this is I would say already very good
and if you catch that so 22 million
would be the sum of the 12 million in
the 10 million here or it says also here
the 22 million the only thing that I
would criticize with this title is that
it is a bit too wordy right you can kind
of formulate the very same message with
fewer words and this is usually always
open teachers because then the reader
doesn't have to go into too much detail
to really get the key message all of it
so one final suggestion expansion to
North America and Asia Pacific with 22
euro million EBIT potential and I would
argue yes there's a civil action title
it summarizes the key message of the
page
it is pretty concise and short you know
it doesn't use too much words to put
those metrics across so I think this
would be a feasible option and of course
in the end I think it's important to
emphasize that of course there's nothing
like the mathematically correct perfect
action title right there are many
feasible options but probably some
action titles are better than others and
I would just really encourage you to
think about you know whether your actual
title is as good as it could be and I
hope that this example kind of gives you
some food for thought in order to get to
that conclusion so just in the end what
I would like you to do is you know again
here in the Q&A section of this course
that kind of appears in the bottom of
the page if you hover here with the
mouse I think it says browse Q&A just
enter maybe an alternative solution that
you came up with and then you have the
opportunity to also check out put other
classmates of yours kind of came up with
and then hopefully you can also learn
from these other solutions that other
people kind of created so guys I hope
you enjoyed this course on creating good
and compelling action titles maybe you
even had a coffee just as I had over
time by watching this and if you would
like to learn more on how to create
these professional consulting style
looking powerpoint slides more than just
Injection title check out the
description below there is a link to my
course but you have basically a full
deck to back course lecture
on how to create presentations that
consulting firms like for instance bgg
or bane module thank you hope to enjoyed
it if you haven't subscribed yet to this
channel please do that but we mean the
world to me thank you and have a good
day